hey hey everybody we're back we're about
the place I'm League of Legends while we
answer some business questions to help
you on your entrepreneurial path it's
Wednesday I'm excited to be here I have
my usual co-host Rishi Cup TV welcome
back Rishi Thank You Evan so happy to be
here and happy Wednesday believe a [ __ ]
I love it what is in our cup today cup
of cup of joy cup of joy no I am Joanne
you a couple min ago why cup of New
Mexico hey Rick Rishi has to go anywhere
I go so yeah it happening what's
happening well maybe you'll find out
later why you just in your cup Evan I
had my vitamin water I'm now having my
regular water and then need to go get
all my other stuff but I'm excited it's
Wednesday its video filming day this is
this is an amazing day for me I love it
so I'm cueing up home we have junior
eyes with me playing under his fresh
reviews account and let's see hopefully
i get my jungle continue to streak two
games let's see we came in three the
street hashtag the streak all right well
let's do it let's get to some questions
what do we got all right first question
comes from a teeth to end yeah a piece
actually is the just kind of wanting to
get your feedback in regards to I guess
emotional health he says how do you
control your emotions while you are at
work everybody has tough time and they
want to achieve something and he says
for me it's been a hard jury and it's
affecting his career and goals
and so he's not really been able to ask
for help but have trusted you enough to
ask you for help and he just basically
wondering if you have a solution to this
problem alright so I absolutely agree
that if you're emotional kind of state
is is not there everything else that you
try to do is going to be difficult and I
will just say that it's very super cool
that you reached out for help because I
think that emotional well-being is
directly tied to your ability to receive
and ask for help and support I actually
just talked about how on one of the
videos on my channel i talked about how
you know like none of us are self-made
really because if you look at anybody's
dirty they got there because of the
support and help of other people
contributing the entire way so i think
you taking this first step is absolutely
the best thing you can do in the
direction towards starting to regain I
don't know emotional health we'll just
call it that and I would encourage you
to keep doing that so as far as some
practical things do just in terms of
let's say you're at work and your
emotions are affecting you do some
things that have helped me are just
taking things a moment at a time and
instead of I think a lot of times when
we get overwhelmed it's because we're
thinking about a big future or we're
thinking about some huge goal that we
have to accomplish instead of just
taking the day piece by piece sometimes
minute by minute so I would encourage
you to make a practice of just taking
your day
and your goals little by little and not
letting them become big overwhelming
things I mean there's so many other
things you could do but that's just one
practical advice i give and and get help
and support because again i think our
emotional health is tied to our ability
to get support from others yeah I like
it um I wishes a little more context in
this one I you know the thing that comes
to mind for me when you're when you when
you don't have clarity or when your life
is kind of spinning out of control and
you're not you're not in control of what
you feel you should be for me it comes
down to having the self-awareness and it
comes back to figuring out what your one
word is so that you can now live your
life with more intention and feel like
you can make decisions with confidence
and clarity and not be not let things
get away from you so as an example on
Monday we had a new personal trainer
come to Toronto dance salsa and I never
met her before right is the first time
so of course we have to get into what
her one word is I have some clarity on
what she's all about and for her she's
all about self-love and that's what she
wants to bring to to her classes and
wants people to field in one just from a
kind of you know impact point of view
making her classes more about self-love
would lead to a better result for the
students right like are you playing
music that is self-love is it like
beyonce and katy perry are you are we
sitting at the end of the class and
saying one thing that we all love about
ourselves what are you telling us while
we're doing our workout that you know
makes me love myself more i should walk
out of that room feeling that i love
myself more than I did when I walked
into the room I
and the thing was something like that is
you'll find that people some people hate
that some people say that's the
stupidest thing ever self-love is stupid
I'm here to I'm here to work out and
that's awesome because you're not really
going to get along with that person the
person thinks that what you staying for
stupid is not going to be a great
long-term fit for your life and when
you're clear about what you're all about
what you stand for what's important to
you then you'll be able to attract the
people that are a good fit that do love
that i would i would love to have a
workout class around self-love man i'd
love to come out feeling like i love
myself more than I did when I walked in
but I get how some people may not like
that and so if if you have now applied
to your situation it works you know are
you clear with what you staying for
what's important to you the values that
mean something to you and then look at
the people in your work environment look
at the decisions that you make on a
day-to-day basis how much of them are
congruent you know how much them are how
much of them are aligned with what you
are all about and you'll probably find
when your life is crazy and out of
control you'll find that there's a lot
that doesn't match up with your one word
there's a lot that doesn't match up with
what you stand for the people around you
you know the work the kind of work that
you're doing you know you you plain
small in certain areas and so I feel
like having clarity over that makes a
big difference and starts having a
massive impact on your life and so
without knowing more about your
situation that's that's where I would
start just trying to figure out your one
word try to figure who you are what you
value most and then look at what is in
your life that is inconsistent with
those values mm-hmm and make some
changes and you feel
maybe for the first time actually in
control of what's happening in your life
it's a pretty powerful feeling that's
what I got yeah and evidence don't worry
I have a follow-up as someone who's
doing so much all the time you've got to
have days where emotionally things are
almost like you know I know I I'll just
say for me there stays you just like oh
I can't even do this XYZ today because
of my emotion is there something that
you do practically to manage your
emotions so that you can continue to do
the work that you do and not have the
emotions holding you back is there
anything that you do specifically did to
kind of manage your emotions so a couple
things one if I find myself continually
upset about something that I know that
means something has to change it's a
signal that this can't continue this way
that it's been always going something
has to change it could be just a
scheduling thing it could be like hey I
need you know I choir a new business I
need to spend time there I don't have
any spots in my calendar so then it
creates stress because it's I haven't
you know given at the time that it needs
and so that means i need to put it in
there a need to pull something else out
or if it's you know you're fighting with
a co-worker all the time when you hate
the idea of going to work as that person
is gonna be there you know like this if
you're constantly upset about the same
thing then something has to change um
to add to that if it's a bunch of little
things that you know are not consistent
that our random one of the things that I
try to do is that is I create a no
crisis business I hate being just me or
engineering and I don't know if this
person is a much firmer assuming that
they said that they have a workplace
right there they're out of job yeah some
it sounds like they have a just a job
great job so it's a little more
difficult you know it's not trying to
plan your own thing but I don't I don't
have a cell phone number I'm not always
checking my email it's hard to reach me
and that's with intent because I want I
don't want to just be putting out fires
I want to be proactive with my time and
making sure that I'm doing things that
I'm passionate about and that's hard a
lot of people aren't a lot of people
spend you know twenty percent of their
time doing things they're passionate
about an eighty percent just reacting to
problems mmm putting out fires picking
up the phone living on somebody else's
time agenda which causes stress at least
for me it causes stress I hate that and
so I you know I changed it so I found
that to be I found that to be pretty
helpful for me and then even just just
asking like thinking about our gratitude
stream this morning asking asking one
extra question like asking a why why is
this important or just realizing what
you know what you do have that you can
be grateful for having you know taking a
couple deep breaths and just realizing
that you are pretty fortunate you it
doesn't mean that doesn't mean you let
people walk all over you right like if
you're in a toxic workplace maybe you
shouldn't be there you can find that you
can find another job somewhere else or
you could start your own thing
so those are some of the things I think
if it's a consistent thing then you need
to find a way to eliminate that from
your life make us make a change somehow
whether it's a people your environment
your schedule and then try to make sure
you're spending your time on things that
are proactive that make you happy that
further your cause that are you know
related to your one word and as little
time as possible just reacting to other
people's agenda yeah good stuff really
good and I think just that Israel of
that he reached out to you Evan but I
think too if you're not reaching into
anyone like it you know that you can
regularly chat with about this type of
stuff that that I would encourage you to
do even though if you keep steady at
some trust issues but I think it's
absolutely vital to find someone with a
friend or mentor I meant when I say mint
or just someone older and wiser that you
can that you can go to or regular
support cool
alrighty next question did you want to
add anything to that end already ready
for the next one no that's good we're
we're having some major fights here so
it's early early whites early fight
early fights already next question is
coming from Kelvin and this is a younger
aspiring entrepreneur Calvin is 17 years
old because I would like to gain some
advice for you as I believe that you
know many of the successful people's
stories of entrepreneurs I often watch
your videos so one of the things he
learned Evan from your channel so far is
that he see from watching you know your
videos that a common trait of successful
people is passion in doing their job and
he's feeling a little torn because for
him his passion is divided between law
and politics or technology he read all
of these stories of world politicians
and got super interested in law and
politics but he had some fears around
pursuing that because of language
writing kind of communication skills he
feels aren't good enough but it's really
passionate about it because he gets to
speak for the Justice and the righteous
of certain aspects and he also sees
themselves kind of speaking to tons of
people with great confidence we've got
he's got a lot of kind of passion for
that for law and politics but then he
also watched some videos about Steve
Jobs and Mark Zuckerberg and started to
do some programming and basically
enjoyed it but he doesn't know if he
would enjoy technology as much unless it
was for the money like I hate he knows
that it's a little bit more enticing
to do that kind of a job because of the
Prophet aspect so that's that's pretty
much what he has to say because I'm a
bit confused between lon technology
would I venture myself into law and
learn about politics and not really earn
a lot of money and yeah but he loves
technology but he doesn't want to do it
just for the money so just kind of
confused and he said would you mind
giving him some advice ok so I we've
gotten a lot of people who have interest
in different areas and they're always
kind of asking for should i do this or
should i do that and i think that the
best thing you can do for yourself is to
realize that um life is not always just
this or that and that there is a way to
merge them in a way that works for you
and I think the main thing that I'm
hearing in this email is that he just
feels like he has to choose this perfect
plan and that it has to be one at the
expense of the other and so I just want
to say that there's many ways that you
could incorporate politics and
technology or law in technology and so I
would just say don't worry about
deciding one or the other right now but
keep trying new things and keep giving
yourself opportunities to experience
different areas in all of these areas
and see what what makes you come alive
and put the money aspect of it too I
mean I know it's important but I don't
think that should be what's driving your
decision
don't worry about the money aspect at
this stage just worry about finding what
makes you come alive and taking it that
step by step by step again going back to
the last question we can get really
caught up in like a big big goal and not
necessarily realize that it's really
about taking smaller chef cool well Timo
jungle has a kill pretty pumped about
that pretty excited um had some early
game chaos these guys are going nuts but
uh oh where I just got a kill nice we're
doing well here um the default answer
that I think of when this comes is
combined them right at the end right
genius at the end instead of just doing
one find a way to do both and that's how
you're going to be unique because if you
just pick one if you just pick
technology you're always going to feel
like there's that little piece missing
yeah and if you just pick politics or
you just pick technology or whatever the
other one you're always gonna feel like
there's something missing and that's
that's the problem right and you'll only
be you'll be you'll be okay at both
right you'll be you'll be you'll be you
know better than average at both because
you love both but you won't be world
class because there's that other piece
that's missing for you mm-hmm and so the
world class pneus comes in from
combining them where nobody will be able
to touch you nobody can do what you do
because you're actually being your best
self nobody can be nobody can out you
you talked about that before on the
channel mm-hmm and so finding what that
is that is unique about you is going to
be important
the thing that kind of sound a little
off though was he did he say that he
won't only wanted to do technology for
the money was that I didn't quite follow
that no well yeah and it was them here's
basically his concern he says whenever I
do something will read something about
technology I always look at it at the
network or profit and I think I'd love I
love to change the world by gaining
money but I he's asking himself a
question it would I pursued technology
if it wasn't profitable and he says I
don't think though so he got he's trying
to ask himself his tougher questions
what I really like technology is it
wasn't profitable because obviously
worth we're living in such a technology
boom right so I'm it's not then it's not
it right so then don't do it and it's
not really your passion no you might
confuse me and he says he really does
like technology later in the email so I
think he doesn't know if it's if it's
because of the money or not but he's
trying to ask themselves a tough
question but you're right if it is just
about money now don't do it and you can
you can maybe incorporate some
technology to help further your cause as
a politician or lawmaker right I don't
know how many politicians you know I
don't know that Donald Trump or Hillary
Clinton are really great on technology
you know that could be an extra angle
that you put in there when I look at
government websites I don't really think
these are really amazing tools range
though that could be a extra bend that
you you bring to it but you have to do
the thing that you would do even if you
weren't making money so figure what that
is
okay yeah so do you oh oh next question
is actually coming from the live shot
all right we got relaxing police station
asking a follow-up question of you
remember oven relaxing police station is
about to pitch a larger channel 4 Club
collaboration yes so he's continued to
ask them the kind of questions around
that so he says how to reach out should
I introduce myself and lay out
everything I want for the collab in 1
e-mail or do I drip-feed while building
a connection say this all in one email I
want to get let me read that again or do
I drift feed while building a connection
say this all in one email I want to get
his attention but I don't want it to be
long too long so he won't bother reading
it I created a video with the original
music and edited a video to go with it i
also created some a new brand intro for
their channel i also created a two
minute teaser video of what they can
expect from the videos if they work with
me nice cool so um yeah i love first of
all relax and swing stations that you
you've been taking me the advice and
actually taking action because that's
actually more rare than people realize
um and i would say i would not probably
send a huge email with a bunch of this
is what needs to happen or this is what
you know i think you're right in that I
would keep it simple and just add value
so you know obviously enough in the
email to introduce yourself and tell
them that you're interested in you know
adding value and then follow up with the
videos that you've made which
sounds like you've over delivered there
which is awesome and then yeah so make
the connection let them know you're
there kit to give value and then I am
quite sure that will open up the door
for a further conversation but I would
not go into all the details of what
collabing is going to look like because
you know I just my sense would be that
that would not be the way to go what do
you think whoa am I gonna die I died
very sad very sad I have two kills in
one yeah very sad okay let me buy
something here um I I would like so I
don't know if they have any initial
contact it sounds like nod I would be I
would be wary of going to far down the
line with someone without getting some
kind of like you can quickly overwhelm
somebody mm-hmm and so I what I would be
doing is try to find a way to get them
on their radar whether that's if it's
making the tribute video whether it's
interact with the social media posts if
it's you know mention them in articles
whatever supporting them if you know
they're active on YouTube and commenting
and being a part of their community
there whatever it is getting on their
radar because if you just go I get
pitched tons of times on collaborations
and you know most of them notch I think
I'm more collaboration friendlier than a
lot of people but it can be it can be
it's to me it's kind of like the same
thing of asking somebody will you be my
mentor you're you're you're asking for a
relationship where they they don't this
this game is nuts man all they want to
do is fight it easy these guys are crazy
anyway um you're asking for something
big when you haven't done anything yet
that's the challenge like yeah so I
would ask anything from anybody until
have given them some value first so i
would not overwhelm them i would not
send them this huge long email when they
don't know who you are and asked
something from them because you i think
you have a pretty low rate of success
mm-hmm but i would be looking at like an
you use that video to get on their radar
can use it to stand out can you use it
to you know make that initial connection
because that's going to be important do
something to stand out do something to
get on somebody's radar start with
something small and then build towards
something a lot bigger you know like I
could have the greatest idea for elon
musk but you know unfortunately Elon
doesn't know me and you know me sending
this giant email is not gonna suck in a
help hmm so do something to get on their
radar first well looks like you've got
all already these videos to pitch so
what do you think it would be best to
you know how would how would you go
about delivering those emails as a way
of giving value well what's in the video
like all I'm looking for is a way to be
able to get on their radar what is that
how do I get on their radar how did how
do they how do I get seen to somebody
who can help
so it just depends as a video a tribute
videos a video something that if I
watching it like as an example I have
the book videos right i made a video
recently for the other day on the
channel two days ago or yesterday Chris
Gila Bo had a book born for this so we
made a motivational video around it and
I sent it to him now already know Chris
but it's an easy way to stay in touch or
four if somebody if I'm producing a new
book and somebody makes a video about my
book I'm going to pay attention right
that's that's getting on my radar that's
providing some values so just the Pens
now if you just write to me say hey Evan
can you can you please be in my video
and recommend this product and let's
let's do this collaboration on my
channel and you know I have no idea who
you are that's a much harder yes to get
that make sense yeah absolutely yeah he
says he created a video and which was a
new brand intro for their channel and he
created a two-minute teaser video what
they could expect from the videos that
they work with him so and then he has
another video that just sounds like it's
unoriginal but yeah I mean I think that
I would definitely start with the video
what do you think about a new brand
intro if someone sent you of an a new
brand intro for your channel um would
that get on your radar I think it would
right um if it was good yeah good then
like a cave a yeah it's like does it add
value you know if my brand channel
sucked and this is something that could
really help me then then I would you
know I would consider it
I died trying to save my my support very
sad um but if it didn't I die you then
then I wouldn't write so just depends
like if somebody sang me a rap song that
was you know really great I would love
it and if somebody sang their rap song
that was really bad you know maybe
appreciate the effort but I don't know
that I would go to share it right so you
know like if you send me this really
scribbled down piece of artwork and say
hey I made this feel like oh wow okay
great but if you said hey my my
two-year-old you know daughter made this
for you like oh cool wow thank you right
so yeah so yeah the vigor can be amazing
or could suck right does it it does the
person think that it's amazing hey you
know if you're selling video services as
an example and I think it's sherry so i
think i think it's i think it's a woman
as opposed i think you said he a couple
times but you know if you sell video
introductions if that's your business
and you make me a video introduction
that's not that bad a way to do it right
like it it gets on my radar and if i'm
looking for video intros then maybe i'm
going to come hire you because you
already did a great one for me you're a
fan of the channel obviously so
the video just has to be good yeah okay
what the help relaxing PlayStation
alright next question is coming from mr.
[ __ ] Tashkent all right and all right
one of our players again decided to quit
the game we have we have all Angry
players man yeah the times good times
okay yeah so do you have what's the next
all right so mr. Tashkent is super fan
any love your videos and they inspire
him is he actually has a follow up about
some of the video personalities he says
have you considered profiling successful
people from Asia Central Asia Pacific
Asia people who have succeeded in their
own home country as opposed to Evan you
know someone from these countries that
go to he makes examples coming to
America and then making it big but he's
wondering about successful people that
you could present from these places that
succeeded in their own home country
because I understand that many of them
come with checkered pasts but in most
cases these things can be overlooked I
recommend your videos to people I know
in the eastern part of the world and
without a doubt all of them say well
those people are great inspiration in
America because they made it in America
you can't apply those inspirations in
our part of the world it just doesn't
apply here and then he ends with on a
personal note I think potentially there
are many people that could become your
fan in the east as long as you could
shed some light on people who have made
it in those
country surely those people are far more
intellectual than average Westerners and
also from a business perspective this
potentially gives you broader audience
to create a following and sell your
materials too and you just basically
says if I it you know if I could help
you with your videos in any way or if
you have any questions I'd be happy to
pay it back to you all right so a couple
of things there one all of the
difficulty the top tens and the in
spreads and the you know the topics that
we cover o our team our team is
surrendering all right um it all comes
from a quest and since most of my
audience is like I'm physically based in
Canada but most of my audience is
American so you know the people that we
end up profiling end up being a lot of
Americans so I would say one like we
have done a number of entrepreneurs who
who were born in their country and
didn't come to America to make a rich
they're in the minority it's not the
most of the people that we do but we've
done a number of them from Asia from
Africa from all over the world and if
there's somebody that you really want a
profile you know listen to how we asked
for request like at the end of every
video I say who do you want me to
profile leave it in the comments below
it's in every single top 10 video who do
you want me to profile and I'm looking
for names right I'm even here you didn't
give me a name like who do you want me
to do give me a name and if you really
want it to happen then rally your
friends come on board and say hey we
want this person to be profiled on the
site and that's how we make a decision
so just based on the number of requests
that we get for different people we put
those together
on top of that I would say if you look
across these people the lessons are the
lessons are almost always the same it
just through a different lens like the
way Michael Jordan looks at success in
the way Elon Musk looks at success in
the way you know Bill Gates like a lot
of the lessons are repeated over and
over and over and over again just with
different words and with a different
face and if you're so upset that you
can't learn like you can learn a lot
from the guys that we're profiling
already I'd really encourage you to not
be that close minded that you can't
learn from Western entrepreneur it's why
I started profiling athletes and all
these other you know singers and people
who aren't the typical entrepreneur I
initially thought just doing
entrepreneurs but I profile to all these
other people because their lessons are
valuable because you can learn a lot
from Michael Jordan even if you never
want to play basketball and I get that
people want to learn from people who
look like them but if you can only learn
from people who look like you you're
going to hold yourself back so it's
opposite ends of the spectrum on one
side you really want somebody profile
great follow the instructions put in
their name tell your friends get lots of
you know people voting for this person
we get a lot of requests for it we'll do
it but on the other side aimed at the
same time it doesn't matter because the
people that we're profiling are amazing
and you can learn a lot from their
success
so they got nice yeah I think I'd be
curious to hear some of the names of the
people that he's referring to I actually
just watched a special on the famous the
females all fur and her name is I'm
going to maybe say wrong but she she on
um I could be thing that wrong but I
guess you know the story was he got
famous once she came to America oh I'd
love to hear about some entrepreneurs
that that are maybe more unknown yeah
put in the request I love learning new
friends too I love learning about I you
know some people have surprised me where
I didn't know what their message was
like a denzel washington or selena gomez
people who i didn't have an opinion on i
didn't know what they would say and they
had like amazing videos great points and
there's other people that i had just
never heard of we look at Africa we did
aliko dangote and strive my CEO and like
all these people that that are unknown
quantities here but our big there they
didn't make their money in America and
also have great lessons to learn from so
I love it to you I would love to learn
from new people I would love to learn
from other agent entrepreneurs who've
just me Tunisia but i also have learned
from North American entrepreneurs and
you know and non non entrepreneurs
around what made them successful you can
pick pieces from everybody so there's no
policy on the channel that it can only
be somebody from America it's just where
we're getting a request from so get your
question
love it all right well the streak is
over we're going to start a new straight
tomorrow Emily get on the victory path
oh we should we didn't start with the
quota that you didn't do a quote we're
gonna end with the quote we're gonna end
up the quota start with a quote we'll
start with a quote what was this to
start with we can end with a quote if
you'd like and with the quote okay well
I'll admit that book but we also have
the three she thought there's a lot of
there's a lot of like these little mini
traditions or building in here we got a
three she was in Bob what's in the cup
thought of the day in the quote I feel
like horse should be in earlier on but
let's see let's hear the coin and with
the quote and the thought of the day
okay so here's the quote that I had
which I love because they actually is
exactly what Evan you just that it's
your message and I hardly believe it and
I'm going to stay in the words of Mother
Teresa he says and let me let me explain
before we go off air she says seek the
face of God in everything everyone
everywhere all the time and seeing his
hand in every happening that's Mother
Teresa and the reason that I like this
is taking you know you're not if you're
not comfortable with the god part hey if
that's okay but the point is when you
can start to see and respect and value
in every single person that you have
something to learn from them there's
something that you can gain I think that
that is a huge principle of success is
not being closed-minded about the value
that people can give you no matter who
they are in every situation everywhere
in every one that's my ghost is a mother
Teresa I love it I love it mother rishi
in the house cool well thank you guys so
much for watching
i'm off to make some videos for the day
hope you're off doing something amazing
continue to believe and cup and rise and
whatever your one word is we'll see you
soon